[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
and ryan's here hi great episode last
week thanks for listening if you didn't
listen to it uh you know
it's it's one of those episodes that's
just
so damn i i really think it's amazing
i've gotten so many
in fact jason isaacs who that interview
is going to come up
early next year you know lucius malfoy
and
the patriot he was the bad guy and great
actor i worked with in sweet november he
said
i just love the i'm not gonna do an
english accent i just love the uh
the episode with tim owenson and selma
blab was just
it really was it was touching and uh so
if you haven't listened to this last
week's episode go back and listen to
that one i think you'll really dig it
and uh
um yeah it's nice when you do an episode
that
you know touches people in a certain way
yeah
so that was cool and kudos to of course
ryan my amazing editor for putting it
together
you know it was moving to to watch again
well actually i mean because i sit over
here and i can't see what they look like
and
i can only just hear it but it's it's
sort of like yeah it's it's a new
experience
getting to see what they're what they
look like and how it's being delivered
yeah so real real quickly a big shout
out
you guys came to uh my uh concert our
band sun spin we played on stage which
we do last saturday of every month
2 p.m and 6 p.m shows pacific standard
time it was a packed crowd
it was great we did zooms we played
music and
the big winners give a shout out here it
is claudine newman
uh top bitter uh team rogue flask
and shannon hagerman shannon and
claudine thank you guys so much for uh
supporting the music supporting the
music supporting the podcast
and also a very big shout out because i
didn't i forgot to
give a shout out to this person who had
won top bidder for the stage it's
a couple of weeks ago and that's leanne
pritchett leanne
lee leanne pritchett is that a big
enough shout out for you
thank you so much clap hands clap hands
yeah my mommy's just saying clap hands
clap hands till daddy comes home
daddy has money and mommy has none
that's what she used to sing
and then she used to say do you want
your real mother to come and i'll leave
i was like that's kind of mean
we don't have to get into the psychology
of that i want everybody to know that uh
when you go to inside of your store and
you get like wine glasses or shirts or
whatever on the
uh inside of your online store i box all
that [ __ ] up
and my patrons are in the top tiers they
get merch every three months so i pack a
box of goodies and i write a little note
personalized
and a little something extra this time
but
i freaking packed 30 boxes
80 envelopes i mean hours
i want you to know how much i i dig in i
appreciate the patrons if you want to
join patreon.com p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon
dot com slash inside of you
and uh join patron it's amazing i always
write you a little note after you join
and uh there are many different tiers
and you get to ask questions to guests
and things like that and inside of me
where you ask me questions and
occasional zoom and lots of cool things
lots of great things and um
so join patreon but thank you all
patrons i i packed it up i took it to
the post office
i stood in line for 40 minutes and uh i
did it all so clap hands for me ryan
clap hands for me what are uh
uh if for subscribing what should they
do i hope you guys all subscribe please
uh
i say it every week but it really helps
the show subscribe on youtube
or um go to uh spotify or apple podcast
stitch or all those things you could uh
also
but it helps when you subscribe and
listen to the show right and go to
insideviewpot on twitter that inside of
you podcast on facebook and instagram
that is correct my friend that is
correct by the way the uh
the band sunspin uh we're working on
logos we just had a photo shoot
and uh we're gonna have sites put uh you
know the instagram and all that stuff
put up soon and i'll let you know about
it but look out for it our music is
coming along we've got like 10 songs the
album's gonna probably be
done hopefully in the next month and um
then we gotta make cds and stuff like
that and all this other stuff
we're really pumped it's a lot of fun
and we're gonna have some merch and
stuff eventually
as well so um and a big shout out to all
the patrons out there who support the
show
who give extra support and thank
everybody for listening
so great guest today um i i've known him
for a long time but he uh you know you
know him from serenity and firefly and
castle and been been everywhere and it
was a real joy talking to him finally
and uh one of those guys i've known for
a long time but i really don't talk to
you very much
um but it was a joy talking to him and a
lot of people wanted me to get him on
on the show and it's taken me a long
time
but finally he said yes and uh i think
you guys are going to really enjoy this
episode it's called
it's called it's called it's called
inside of you this is nathan fillion
let's get inside of the great nathan
fillion
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
when i got about you i just can't get in
my mind
i just can't get enough just getting you
son of a bee
nathan fillion look at your mustache is
perfect you know what uh
it's my first i'm i'm nearly 50 years
old i turned 49
uh this spring it's my first mustache
ever ever
and uh right now i mean nobody sees it
it's just for shock value when i first
see my friends uh for the first time in
a little while they go oh
well i was gonna say why do you look so
much more handsome than me
but there's a reason for that because
you are but b
your camera system one thing about
nathan that you don't know is
many years ago i was uh
i was at his house on hill i lived on
hill sub studio city and you live right
near me
and uh i remember talking i go yeah i
just
shot this wiffle ball game video because
my friends and i are playing in indiana
welcome to my house let's edit it like
oh what and we sat down at your computer
for i think it was like 10 hours
well yeah i said ah we'll be done in
like an hour and a half two hours max
and we were there till oh my god it was
after midnight we were ordering food we
were drained
but i mean it was imovie had just come
out
yeah so you could you could do your own
things but you had to
put in clips uh slowly because it
couldn't handle
vast amounts of the rendering yeah how
are you doing buddy
i'm doing well man i you know i miss you
and i uh i've been doing all right you
know i talk about that you know ever
everybody's going through their own [ __ ]
so it's like you know no one could
complain i mean i'm
very grateful i've learned and by the
way
i think you're an example of that you're
someone who's always been incredibly
grateful
the nathan that i know is just been
always been very
i mean when you come to uh uh even like
uh james gunn will throw a you know i'm
name dropping but you know we're mutual
friends with him for a long time
and they'll have a gathering and you'll
bring something over you bring me a gift
at a party
no one does that like i'll have an event
and you'll come over and go hey this is
for you i got this
you're just so thoughtful and i'm like
is he human
that's something i got my mom uh taught
me that but uh
she says if someone has uh invited you
to their home
you bring the host a gift and say thank
you thank you for having me in your home
here's a little gift
it doesn't have to be much but it's just
to say it's something it's a it's a
bottle of wine it's
whatever it is it goes a long way yeah
i'll say that she has
she has a gift closet by the way so she
doesn't have to go out and get one she
just
goes to the closet so i have a gift
closet down the hall when i
go to michael no you don't you have a
closet with gifts there already
that you're like oh rose and mom would
like this so you how much time do you
just accumulate a closet full of
things yeah so i i love
gadgets and gizmos and things that are
cool and make my life better just little
little things little tiny things and i
say that's a good that's a game changer
oh my god i never knew my iphone cable
is
uh terrible because it's only it's not
10 feet long i need a 10 foot long
iphone
it's life-changing man it really is i'm
on my you know i sit there you know i
it's tethered to wherever it's charging
if you have to get on something it's
like
you're limited to where you can be well
get a little battery a little something
anything
i i say oh i find something like that
and i just say oh this is amazing this
this
helps me i'm gonna buy five more and put
them in the closet
wow maybe i should do that just have a
closet full of presents for my family
and friends and
oh [ __ ] i forgot to give them this two
years ago yeah
you ever done that yes yes
yes oh my god i once sent something
uh to my brother to uh yes did you
met jeff of course to give to my mom for
something and it didn't arrive in time
and uh and so i got her something else
and uh
i don't know how many months later it
was mother's day or her birthday like
there's one or the other and she he's
telling me
on the day oh it's her birthday
i i forgot what am i gonna he goes don't
worry
i've got that thing in the closet that
you ordered her from something i've
already had it wrapped and it's ready to
go like this
he's clever too well you know man i look
i mean your body of work is just like
you know nate you're always doing
something and it's hard to understand
too i envy you not
not only because you work a lot it's not
about that it's more about
the energy i look at like all the things
you do like you go from seven seasons on
castle and i thought you'd learn your
lesson and say that's enough work
that's enough work i was the lead and
then you go into the rookie
and then you're doing all these other
things and is it is it that you love
i've asked this question every once in a
while but is it that you love the work
so much
that you just want to work or is it that
you don't want to be
not working or you don't like being
alone what is is there some kind of uh
psychological thing there or is it just
you love work i don't
get it uh i am not the guy who has to
spend
all my time working i like a balance
i do like a balance i have been
fortunate enough that
uh there's been a couple of jobs that
have kept me working
for long periods of time so it may
appear from the outside
that i i really like to work that's just
luck of the draw of being on some jobs
that
that that will tend to last a little
while and
that's not usually the uh
how it works which is you know that you
know that how many years was small
i did seven but remember thomas was that
all tom was in every episode like you
are in every episode so how do you have
free time
because the one thing if i had two weeks
off i'd be worrying about my lines for
the next script
uh i yeah on castle it was a little
different because i didn't have a lot of
time off so i was really
precious with my time off i wasn't
trying to work outside of
of castle uh as far as how do you
remember your lines
my first gig was soap opera all right
days of our lives one life to live one
live tournament
yes thank you and uh they sent me to an
acting coach and she said
you already know how to act i'm just
going to teach you how to break down a
script
so you can remember your lines and she
taught me a way that i use to this day
i used to do it painstakingly you know
on paper and pen and have to study and
do those
but now it's just a it's just a muscle
wait a minute so there's a trick to the
thing there's
there's a breakdown a certain way to
learn them that helps i mean i
i just no one ever taught me anything i
took acting classes and then i got did a
lot of plays
but i just went over and over and over
and over and stressed myself out there's
an easier way to do it something that's
what is your process when you start with
a character where do you start and how
do you get to your character how do you
find things like what does
you have a process right yeah i feel
like okay this is what i want to do
and now once i feel like i got this
i or sometimes i tend to learn the lines
first
and then find the character in the lines
and learning
so it's a different thing but i always
am curious about how people do that
because when you're on castle and you're
on rookie and you're doing these movies
are you the guy that wakes up and
they're like uh
nathan do they say native they say
nathan okay they say
can i get you a coffee and you're like
yeah and then you learn lines right in
the chair
yes yes i'm reading the lines in the
chair
um then you go in you do a camera
rehearsal you do a couple rehearsals you
know like that
and you get a little bit of a layout so
that educates you and then how other
people are doing their lines and where
that kind of
life lives that educates you a little
bit then you go okay i got it now
and then you run it a couple more times
as you're getting changed and that's all
you need really and then you just then
you're just running it and running and
running it
if you make a mistake they go back it's
not like you have to be amazing and
perfect every time all the time but
there's got to be a speech that you have
to give that you you know i might need
to go over this the night before
uh i won't lie to you i had like a three
page it wasn't a monologue but it was
there was a lot
to say and that's it's a lot for even me
and i'm good at that part of it but that
was
a lot and uh at that point you do feel
some responsibility if you
make a mistake you're the one holding
things up and that's just the one thing
i never want to be is the one people are
waiting on
just be ready there's a lot of time in
the day that you can use
when it's your time to work just be
ready do you get frustrated with other
people if they don't know their lines
uh listen sometimes people get nervous
and they don't have the pr
i have so much practice i have so much
practice
uh i think folks come and their stakes
are a little higher when they're a guest
star sometimes the stakes get higher if
they make a mistake they feel terrible
and i say hey
uh if you feel like super duper bad
about messing up a line it'll educate
the crew
that maybe i should start feeling bad
when i mess up a lot
i don't want them to have that kind of
expectation i believe that you do that
because i've heard that you do that
where you've been on set and you're just
very comforting to guest stars and
things and
i've done that before too because coming
into someone's family
and expecting to be it's so intimidating
and i've been fortunate enough not to
have to do that
so you know not to be a guest star i
mean every once in a while but
to come in on a show that's already
rolling let's go and like
i have to be great i have to be great
here's nathan philly and [ __ ] he's the
lead he's watching me have to impress
him i
i well i can't tell you what they're
thinking i do know that uh to be a guest
on a show is a is an art
it's you have it's like being a guest in
someone's house you want to be
relaxed listen i want people to be
relaxed in my home when people come to
my place of work i want them to be
relaxed there too because that's when
they're going to do their best work
when they feel like they can trust
everyone enough there that they can try
something and fail and it's okay
that's where i want them to be that
makes perfect sense
have you ever been one because i've
always you always seem together you
always seem like you have it going on
you're professional you're kind
do you ever have you been on sets or in
the past
have you freaked out have you have you
gotten so nervous
or you can't get something or you were
so worked up about something any job
where you're just like i remember that
and that was uncomfortable i never
what was it yeah i uh saving private
ryan
i had one job i come in and go yes they
say your brothers are dead and i have to
cry and that's all i have to do
that's it just do it and
i was just it was it was all my first
it was my first movie and it's a world
war ii period piece and they flew me to
london
and i'm looking at the ticket and the
ticket cost more than
i'm making to do the movie and i'm i
just can't even understand and the hotel
i'm staying
is beautiful i've never been to london
before and the time change
i was i was beside myself everything's
going on and there's all these huge
movie stars around me and they go
go and i'm supposed to okay
and i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't
well can't they blow vapor in your eyes
i'm sure they can this is a stephen
spielberg movie i'm not interested in
cutting any corners
i'm really not did he come and talk to
you like uh nathan yeah
steven spielberg came and took me aside
and he said great job
and i said i don't i'm not even i don't
i'm not even crying i can't even
i can't get there and he said listen
we're so far away in the lens
it doesn't matter there's five of us in
that video booth we all bought it
what i'm hearing you saying is that
wherever it is here it's not coming out
here from the heart to the to the
outside world so let's talk about it
and he spends maybe two three minutes
talking to me about
i tell him my homework and he said okay
let's change this and this and what if
it's this
and now think about this and now turn
that camera of your mind's eye around
and who's looking at that
and all of a sudden oh my god it's just
it's tragic and it's awful and i start
crying
listening to him he says you look ready
how do you feel
and off we go he couldn't stop me from
crying he cried 17 times that day
that's so freaking weird because i you
know that that was
my first moment on a movie was i had to
cry
with clint eastwood midnight in the
garden of good and evil and clint
eastwood that the first scene they
ended up cutting the scene because they
didn't really need it but i it was john
crusek kevin spacey
uh clint eastwood's there and i remember
the same thing i'm listening to
fleetwood mac because it reminds me of
something in childhood
and i'm trying to listen to music and
get in the moment i'm so into it i'm so
stressed and i'm probably doing what you
were doing just kind of
whenever i got to get there spending
hours on just to cry
and eastwood comes up to me and he just
sits next to me
and he just starts pretending to cry he
just goes
and i look at him like oh lucy what are
you doing
and he goes well i'm just trying to
loosen you up michael
i go well i guess just let it happen
it'll just
it will happen you just let it go
and when you're ready when you're ready
we'll roll that's it it's not it just
it amazes me that that giant cowboy a
giant
rock of a man is artsy
oh and he when i heard you know he
doesn't call
action he didn't he goes he looked at me
and he just i looked at him and he just
goes
he gave me a thumbs up and i gave him a
thumbs up and he goes
jack did the roll
jack green the roll sign and he started
rolling camera they moved in did it goes
well how'd you feel i go i don't know
how did you feel he goes
well i feel pretty good there i go you
want another but we're good and we did
another that was it
it was just you know and that says a lot
it says about two great directors it
says
also back to what you're saying about
with guest stars comforting someone just
saying
hey we're human it's okay
let's just do this it's not as much
pressure on you
you're capable you're here for a reason
and when you're comfortable
you could do a lot more you know when
you're freaking out it's hard to
get the job done so i've guested in
places where i look around and i say
this
the community here is broken
and i can't focus all i can think about
is
just get me out of here let me do my
lines doing my scene let me go home
that's all i'm thinking about get me out
get me out
i can't wait till i'm gone and i'm not
doing good work at that point
i'm uncomfortable i don't trust anybody
when has that happened
early in my career early on wow i mean
as a leader of
a show do you tend to just try to do i
mean you've got to do your best to cut
you got to be the leader you got to
try to have fun if everything's tense
things aren't going to be as good and i
don't i don't think it's even that much
like you have to be a lead
you just have to be it just just be nice
just be nice just be polite just be nice
just be decent just
just be kind well you talked about your
mom she's kind she's talking about gifts
always bring a gift
were your parents just really supportive
and always behind you and just uh
absolutely absolutely they were dying
for me to show interest
in any direction honestly when i was a
kid i had
i had really no wants or thoughts about
what i was
they had no plan uh and they were just
always very very encouraging and if i
found something that
that you know tickled me they would
encourage me absolutely yeah but you
didn't want to be an actor at first you
wanted to be maybe a
did you want to be a teacher is that
right well acting it was
a pipe dream i mean i was from edmonton
alberta i was
this it's not a success oriented career
in the first place
never mind in my hometown there's just
no nobody's gonna look at you and go
perfect great plan but uh i was already
on the road to becoming a teacher i felt
if i have a degree at the very least no
one can shake a stick of that
and so i was pursuing a degree and then
just before i graduated i i
the acting panned out i moved to new
york were you popular in school
athletic i looked athletic
but i was into comics so i there was the
the gap i could bridge that gap i hung
out with all the kids at school i was
i was i had a great time in high school
i really enjoyed my high school
experience i met a lot of neat kids from
all over the strata i didn't stop at you
know just one click or
do you still talk to anybody from the
old days high school days
yes yeah yes i do do people come out of
the woodwork and say
hey could you sign something from my
brother or do you get that sometimes no
i don't get a lot of that
no no i don't get a lot of that i went
to my 25-year high school reunion not
too long ago
um i think it was 25 here they took a
couple of years together it was a small
high school and and so they took a
couple of years
and they said everybody were having like
a big reunion with all these ears
and what was that like it was fantastic
it's just the people that i knew in high
school
it was like this girl from my french
guys just sit next to me in french class
all the time
uh she came up to me she goes well i
know everything that's going on with you
so let me catch you up on me i've got
two kids i'm married and have and she
just goes on but she's hilarious and
she's just the same person she used to
be
i enjoyed high school were you single
when you went to this reunion were there
any single women that you're like hey
i'm going to quit my acting degree i'm
going to move back to alberta
i found her uh no it wasn't no that
wasn't that deal now
most people were married probably kids
married uh
i i yeah i think so i think most of them
were yeah
but you had a good time what happens
after high school people typically
typically they marry off and whatnot
yeah
just i haven't uh just don't meet you
inside of you is brought to you by geico
even an actor can do it right i mean
it's true
geico is that easy geico is easy i can
do geico
that's impressive isn't it yeah i mean
you remember those commercials that
even a caveman could do it even or even
a rosenbomb can do it even a rosenbaum
can do it even a rosenbaum can do it
geico geico brought to you by
uh we know out there you either rent or
you own your home
uh i mean that's what we do and it's
always the hardest thing to do
and uh you you know it's actually easy
and it it just is easier the bundling
policies with geico
so you know you have auto insurance and
home owners or renters
i mean you can combine them wouldn't it
be easy if you could just like you don't
have to go
separately ryan i think so geico makes
it freaking
easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance
along with your auto policy geico it's a
good thing
because you know you already have so
much to do around your house and all the
holidays go to geico.com
get a quote see how much you could save
geico easy it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbomb can do it inside of you
is brought to you by mac weldon
i wear their stuff constantly and it's
you know i i've never been more
comfortable
my the underwear that i'm wearing is so
comfortable i have a
mask like one of those things that you
put over your face the
the neck things oh yeah they're so
comfortable and they look kind of cool
when it comes to holiday gifting for
guys i'll be the first to admit that
it's not necessarily my strong suit
but now thanks to mac weldon it's easy
super easy it's simple define something
great no matter which guy you're
shopping for i'm a guy i like
very comfortable underwear and lounge
pants and and i like
top i want to feel like i'm naked if i
can't be naked i want to
feel comfortable close to naked you
understand me
and uh i love their stuff mac weldon has
men's basics that are guaranteed to keep
everyone on your list comfortable
and you know what makes mac weldon the
perfect gift for guys and i'll tell you
quality comfort versatility
style shopping ease it's very simple to
just go to macweldon.com
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n-dot-com
and just enter the promo code iou and
you're gonna get uh you're gonna get
good stuff you're gonna get 20
off your first order it's the gift
giving season folks
they've got a loyalty program level one
gets you shipping for life
once you reach level 2 by spending 200
bucks mac welding gives you 20
off every order for for the next year
uh this is pretty fantastic when the
gift giving
season get 20 off your first order visit
mack macweldon.com iou
enter the promo code iou what is that
ryan macwilden.com
iou promo code iou for 20
off your first order that sounds pretty
amazing you should probably get to it
thank you
what was the big thing you got that you
just it lit up your parents eyes you
could tell like well holy crap our son's
done something right here so i i i was
comparing stories with some friends
little while ago when did you make it
when do you feel that you
made it like when was your here i am
and right for me it was every next
step i took i thought well i made it
clearly
one life to live i've made it yeah and
then i'd put something in the distance
like
if i can get on the late show with david
letterman if i can get on david
letterman right
i'll have made it and then you then i
did it happened i
had a dream come true i couldn't believe
it and then you set another goal and you
say if i get i'll make it
then i'll have made it i need to go to
your psychiatrist
or if you don't have one i need to go to
you i need to pay you to talk
because we just come from two different
places you know when i first got my
first show in um
in la uh i thought i'd made it
i drove cross country with all my guys
we wore overalls and we said we're not
changing our overalls until we hit vegas
we had a volkswagen runners
i guess we were dexter midnight runners
what was the big hit
in a van again dream uh so we yeah we so
we changed all our clothes in vegas and
we
drove out there and i go i've done it
man i got
this kid from small town went to new
york did some off-broadway shows and now
he's got a tv show and i thought
everything changes now
and i wasn't the lead i was like the
sixth lead and i had you know not that
well it was ranked like 1 30 out of 132
one of the worst shows on television
by the way thank you but here and you
know what's funny is
it wasn't just no one paid attention to
me
it was that my parents my family my
own family would even talk [ __ ] about it
they would say god that show looks just
awful doesn't it do they shoot that on
what do they shoot that on i'm like
uh video i i don't know it's like oh my
gosh it's just the dialogue it's just
awful isn't i'm like oh my god this is i
have not made it
this is and so i feel like
i was always trying to get ahead like
okay what about this show
oh my god we're on the subways wherever
they canceled i so it's always
and i find that now that i'm 48 years
old and i'm like
well michael it's not about what you're
doing it's about how you feel inside and
what you feel that you've done and your
accomplishments and what is that mr hand
what is it that you've i don't know why
i started talking like that but
my point is how do you differentiate do
you get frustrated in the thought of
like
oh man this didn't become this or oh
in terms of how successful it is is that
do you feel better when it's more
successful i mean
i don't know i see what you mean um i
mean early on
in my career i had a couple of things
happen that
uh allowed me some perspective as far as
managing expectations so
i hope for the best i plan for the worst
listen i'm doing that now
i have that attitude now finally i go
hey
can 150 000 people listen again this
week great right
if they don't i'm not i'm just doing it
i love it i whatever
there's a few things that are within
your control yeah
and there are some things that aren't
and if you can if you can determine the
difference
and then just focus and just worry
about things that are within your
control it's it's listen i talk about it
like it's easy oh all you got to do is
but
it's not easy and i you know you have to
catch yourself all the time it's a
constant process but
if it's outside of your control let it
go
if it's within your control control
it if you want to do a great job on an
audition
you can't control what they think but
you can control
your part you can control the audition
you can control your preparation you can
control your
character choices you can control just
be prepared yeah just be prepared man
if it's that important be prepared
that's in your control um so it's so
easy
as success goes how can you not
look at your career and say oh my god
how fortunate am i i mean
make a list of all the actors in the
industry
and then just highlight the ones that
have been on a television show
for seven years the list becomes
dramatically shorter it's
not easy so you have already
accomplished something that
it's not impossible to do
and so much of that is outside of your
control you didn't know that today was
going to be therapy for me did you
because this is what the show is a lot
of times it's
it's therapy for me you know that i
think all of
us sometimes i mean i think we're as
culturally i think we are
sort of told hey hey like don't
play it down a little bit just back up a
little bit when you talk about yourself
don't pump yourself up so much nobody
wants to it's bragging
if you talk but it's not bragging
or uh egotistical or selfish in any way
to take inventory of your
accomplishments
what you have done and what you're able
to do and qualities that
don't deny oh i'm not so nice no you
know
how kind you are take an inventory
you are where you are because of the
choices you've made and the person you
are
you are a success and sometimes it's
important that we do
take those inventories and i think
that's what we're doing right now we're
just taking a little inventory
yeah thank you do you do you get anxiety
have you suffered from any depression
have you dealt with things that you have
to get help for
absolutely absolutely oh good
good i mean not good but i had that
seasonal disorder where you
i get depressed in winter if i don't see
sun for a long time
i just it it it takes me physically it
it pulls me down uh now they have those
beautiful
uh lights these uh full spectrum lights
that if you're in vancouver for
months at a time when it's raining turn
on one of these lights a couple times a
day you get your vitamin d you get your
you know
you have those lights oh heck yeah you
do god bless i'm gonna get the lights
from you i'm gonna get the set up for
the
i got them in the gift closing i mean
but when you get depressed when you get
anxiety where does your mind go do you
do you get like
would you get down on yourself do you
get down on like why am i here do you
get existential
what is it that that gets you down and
and what do you do about it i
i'll i'll worry and i'll stress and i'll
um
i'll close off a little bit and i'll
withdraw
i'll withdraw i'll be cranky and i'll
withdraw um
it just takes a little time because i
can't spend too much time like that
uh it's that sense of
what am i going to do now you only spend
so much time in that
question until you say well got to do
something and you start doing something
it's when i start doing something that i
feel better
i was stressed out it's a pandemic
we are all incredibly stressed out right
now to deny that would be silly but
people are stressed i'm stressed
building this
facility to help me continue to work to
help me
uh i actually sat here and had drinks
with my brother and
my good buddy in canada just last night
we just sat around
for four hours doing this i built this
so i could do these things
it settles me a bit uh a project
cleaning oh my god are you ocd are you
ocd do you like things really clean i am
not ocd
i am the opposite of i collect i uh
i start i'm not gonna say i'm a hoarder
but boy i'll look at stuff and i'll go
that's clutter
that's just clutter i gotta go through
that and say i don't have an emotional
attachment to any of these things
but it's still good stuff but it's gotta
go to like a goodwill or something
that's gonna go off
this is just garbage these things i can
organize and now i feel fresh but that's
that's time consuming well you were a
comic book collector right you love
comics growing up
now many guests have commented on oh
like a jerk poster it's autographed and
this i have autographed things and
pictures
and most of them 99 of them are like
i don't do that and i'm like what do you
mean they're like yeah you know i don't
like why did i ask somebody i'm working
with or
why do you need autographs it's just
something i think i i don't know why but
i love that
do you get autographs do you get
pictures do you you are like that i've
got a bit of a collection things that
things that ring uh inside me as far as
make my my heart move i've got my
chewbacca autograph
my r2d2 uh my um
uh marty and doc brown uh
autograph i've got my uh batman and
robin the adam west and uh
uh i'm sort of forgetting dick
ward's name the robin character i can't
remember his name i'm so embarrassed
but uh the old-timey one um uh
i've got some souvenirs from my
different films that i've been in i i
purchased a home about a little over 10
years ago and it had a trophy case
and i thought what am i going to do with
it i know exactly what i'm going to do
with this
and now all my movie memorabilia are
another like lit
mirrored cabinet i remember that because
i remember coming to your house for
something and you walk in the front door
and there it was
that was like good for him i'm usually
hiding this [ __ ] in my podcast room
because i try to prove to everybody when
they come to my house that i'm a [ __ ]
adult
look it's a living room there's no
pictures of po there's no posters
there's no figurines just don't go in
the podcast room or my office or maybe
downstairs but other than that you
haven't you haven't moved you're in the
same house
same house okay we're still very close
by
um that house is sort of like a cabin
it's sort of like a castle and it's sort
of like a treehouse
yeah it's kind of fitting us has
adventure
written all over i i do love it i'm
always thinking you know because
during this time and i don't know what's
going i'm getting in this phase where
i'm like
i want to i want to get away i want to
like people are starting to leave and
i'm not saying like leave la and like
i'm just more like i need nature i've
been watching that show alone
on the history channel and i had a guest
on here what are you looking for
beach or mountains i think i want like
you know
i liked a view in the back or trees or
maybe a lake in the back you know
some water like i was looking at big
bear actually because it's like
somewhat reasonable and you go out there
and it's nice and maybe snow in the
winter and
you know i don't know i just i i wonder
if it's just all mid-life crisis [ __ ]
though oh you got to get out
you're not and i think par you don't
think so i don't think that is i
i have been buying property in canada
for
years and now i'm actually
seriously pursuing it it's it's like
it's time
it's time i'm i'm going to look now with
you know some seriousness and
uh it's something i've always wanted to
do i i don't think i'll retire
and live in los angeles i don't think i
will i think i will retire and
live my summers in uh western canada and
my winter's
somewhere warmer that's my it's my plan
i hate to be that guy and i don't think
i am but
you know i don't know how healthy la
maybe is for me
um i've got my own kind of thing and i
you know
i'm able to write and do but i'm like oh
you could do a podcast you could write
you could put yourself on tape you can
go to meetings you could do whatever you
want you can come back in you get flying
you could zoom
if you want you know maybe it's maybe my
health i'd feel just better
if i was just around nature more i know
that was it's probably true
we have to that's i mean for some people
i have a friend who just absolutely
abhors nature he wants the city life he
wants a suburb he wants
sky rises it's it's variations of urban
is what he can handle um
if he's out camping and there's like a
skitter of a creature i'm out
i'm out there's animals out here he
can't handle it
i i want to breathe in that air i want
to see
the the mountains the lake the ocean
whatever it might be
i want to recharge like that i want my
bare feet on the ground or in the water
i
want that i want that recharge i think
that's natural i know i see that i
remember just seeing pictures and things
that you do with your brother you go on
these excursions you're so close and you
go to
scuba diving i can't go to school i
can't go scuba diving i
i'm scared ever since the pilot episode
of smallville we had to get scuba
certified and i had to go under 12 feet
of water
and be they put like weights on me
and then clark had to come save me i
freaked out being under water so much
and i just feel claustrophobic and it
scares me that i'm gonna have one of
those
i'm not smart enough i feel like uh are
you there
you're there then i'm gonna go down
frozen i'm gonna go down
i'm gonna go down a certain level and
you have to decompress or whatever the
pressure i worry about that and i'm like
oh my god did i do that i'm going to end
up killing myself it's scary scuba
diving is it not
well certainly if you're claustrophobic
and it's triggering claustrophobia
yeah that would be scary i'm scared of
drowning i'm terrified of drowning but
i'm not scared of scuba diving how about
snorkeling that seems pretty cool
it's i mean that's the closest thing to
being in another world that i've ever
experienced that's another planet that
like
it's like you have abilities you can fly
around and it's
just it's i love the
ceremony of it i love the travel i love
the
seeing things i have the opportunity and
i i love
built making memories like that and i
think it's one of the most
fantastic things i can do with the money
i've earned is
uh well one thing is planned for the
future that's a big thing for me
plan for the future and uh make memories
enjoy
memories do you want to do you want like
listen i'm 48 i feel like i could ask
you this
you're 50. i've been over nine mister
back it up
49 sorry you're 49. i'm very grateful
you're grateful well
we're all but you know my grandma maybe
it's because my grandma's
chirping in my ear and she has been she
goes when are you going to get married
when are you going to have kids you'd be
such a good dad you're going to be such
a good
a do you hear this from your mom and b
do you really think
you want to get married and have kids or
you want to get married have you thought
or do you think
you know what i like being alone and
being in relationships every once in a
while and that's how i
think i am wired uh
as far as my parents expectations
i think uh my parents
understand that their choices and their
schedule
was good for them and right for them
at their time when the world was a
certain way
and when their choices were what they
were
uh my the world around us
you and i right now is different our
industry is
different i'm i'm a little displaced
uh there's a lot of things that are a
little bit different but i think my
parents understand that i am not
in the same world or on the same
schedule
so and and they already have two
spectacular grandkids that they're
really really pleased with so that took
a lot of pressure on
that's good but do you think like you
ever look in the future and go
you know maybe i'll get married someday
or
uh i don't know why why do i have to get
married why does you just be with
someone or
or do you feel that kind of pressure or
societal [ __ ]
i don't feel pressured man and as far as
what's gonna happen in the future i mean
i look at my life and i think
i never once imagined my life would be
exactly what it is right now uh this is
the dream
for me i was i was locked up in canadian
winters depressed as a kid going this is
really rotten i wish i could ride my
bike and some sunshine
and i now i live in los angeles i'm i
i pretend for a living i
um we make believe i mean
boil it down it's we get together
and we do really high quality
make-believe
i love my job i love hanging out and
meeting people like you
michael i'm gonna change the subject
really quick
it's a good call i was just thinking
about you wouldn't i was just thinking
about it
just hanging out as i was getting ready
for this
podcast and i have known you for over
20 years yeah i can't remember where we
met
i was gonna ask you that question too to
start off i've i've known you for so
long
well you were doing uh a guy girl in a
pizza place two guys grill pizza place
and you were doing small bill
uh no i was doing well i was doing the
show that didn't do very well i talked
about earlier and then i was doing a
show called
uh well it's called the tom show he
knows it was bad it was tom arnold ed
mcmahon
i mean you know but i had a great time i
was right next to ed mcmahon's trailer
he had a bentley and i had a volkswagen
bus
1982 and every day he'd go indiana
how are you sir i go pretty good ed i i
was so cold last night
i would do a car sprinter and he would
go how cold was it i go
so cold i saw robin putting his worm in
the microwave
weird wild stuff ed and he would laugh
and
he would sleep during rehearsals and it
was just a treat man
and i loved it it was it's a shame that
you see what i do
i'm remembering great moments but the
moments that take me out of it are
moments
that judge me or judge the show that i'm
on it's not living in the moment it's
worried about other
uh external things that i just put that
together
so i just told you a funny moment some
great times i used to take a go-kart
dried the universal rides i had so much
fun if i think about it was probably one
of the best times of my life
but i allow other external the piece of
[ __ ] show what is this doing what is
this no one likes it my family's rude
you know to affect the way i feel
i read an article that said what's the
difference between lucky people and
unlucky people and they said it was
perspective well
that's that's that's what i said my
grandmother one of her favorite sayings
if you said oh well this happened that
wasn't very good like you give her some
badness she well at least you got legs
she was sick at least she got legs hey
are you friends with justin trudeau
i met justin trudeau one time uh he was
it was a charity event it's just before
he was prime minister it was a charity
event and it was a pickup hockey game
and he had just got checked up against
the boards and i was
kind of right there and we and he's
getting cracked and
everybody's laughing he laughs he looks
at me and say oh hey i know you
and then he continually went off and
played hockey and then i got to meet him
a little later on at
a at a a little a dinner and he was very
pleasant man very pleasant man so we met
the one time
all right so you know you know because
the internet the internet says
oh canadians are friends and uh
you don't really killed me one time as i
i told somebody where i was from they
said oh hey do you know uh
and i come on man
i'm not gonna know your canadian friend
and it turned out i knew their canadian
friend
you really knew they're canadian friend
one time someone said
oh i'm from canada i said oh where are
you from in canada oh you would never
heard of it
they didn't know i was canadian i said
try me and they said i'm from
uh boyle alberta and i said well tell me
this do brad and scotty and their family
still own the uh
general store and hotel in boyle
how do you know that yeah their mom was
my mom's best friend we used to go out
to boil alberta and we would
they owned the general store which was
connected to the hotel and that was
where we would stay
and we have these adventures out in the
country and it just
happened i knew her hometown intimately
by the way there's a town called dildo
newfoundland did you know that i don't
know there is and come by chance
come by chance come by chance does it
come by chance and a dildo
and uh fairyland fairyland
by the way in canada do they really say
we're going for a rep there bud can we
go for a rep
uh it is it is said i mean
my buddies didn't say that much
they didn't say rips yeah yeah yeah
i mean some people would say that yes
yeah i know looney and toonie and
tuke and uh yeah i have a lot of
canadians what a poser is
yeah what is a hoser i know the word hey
hoser from uh yeah
if you were playing hockey uh with your
friends and you lost
the losers of the game would have to
hose down the ice oh
the next yeah so a horse or something
yeah if you're doing a pickup game with
just you
you've been making an ice rink you know
in your backyard and you're having
hockey games with your buddies
you don't have a zamboni so you just
re-hose the ice so
posers are the losers of the game you
lost the game
inside of you is brought to you by blue
chew i don't know about you ryan but i'm
48 and i could lose a boner i don't care
i'll tell you
i mean it's just the facts i mean a lot
of people won't get private i don't
you know i'm a human i go to therapy i
uh
i have flaws uh sometimes i need a
little help in the old bedroom
you know you're not alone is what i'm
trying to say it's
you know uh it's it's not an
embarrassing thing these are things that
every urologist or whatever
talks to their patients about and
they're like the the patient's always
like oh well you know my
my bones aren't as strong as i was like
and he's like do you think they haven't
heard this
get the only sildenafil and tadalafil
chewables by visiting bluechewed.com if
you like sex
you'll love bluechew.com i love
bluechew.com
bluechu.com offers men a performance
enhancement for the bedroom
and at bluechew.com you can get the
first chewables
that's pretty awesome with the active
ingredients sildenafil
tatallophil same ingredients as viagra
and cialis
bluechew.com affiliated physicians work
with you to find the dosage and active
ingredient that is best for you
yeah and this is something for me i
always was like do i need to eat a steak
before i have this or
empty stomach here's a great thing the
chewables from bluetooth.com can be
taken on a fuller empty stomach
online physician consult is free it's
cheaper
than the other ones you know the
viagra's and the ci alice's it's cheaper
why wouldn't you go to bluetooth.com
it takes a few minutes to connect with
the bluetooth.com affiliated physician
and if you qualify you get prescribed
online quickly
ships directly to your door in discrete
packaging
the chewables from bluetooth.com are
made in the usa you and your partner
will love it
chew it do it visit bluechew.com and get
your first order free when you use the
promo
code inside just paying five dollars for
shipping that's b-l-u-e-chew.com
promo code inside bluechu.com promo code
inside hey this real quick is called
[ __ ] talking with rosenbaum it's really
[ __ ] talking with nathan fillion
it's from my patrons they're awesome
they get to ask some questions
rapid fire you just ask them how it is
uh
lisa hall flask girl is it true that
when you were weren't the first pick for
the role of firefly and originally joss
wrote the character with nicholas
brendan in mind but scheduling conflicts
gained you the role
not true not true not to my knowledge
there you go
that was true nicholas never told me raj
dr horrible sing-along
blog is one of my favorite musicals of
all time i even dressed as captain
hammer for halloween one year raj for
the love of all that is holy please tell
me there has been progress in putting
together a sequel
i have heard the title
of a sequel that is the extent of what
i've heard about
d kent what was it like to work with
sarah michelle geller and david boreanaz
during the last episode of buffy and do
you still keep in touch with them
uh oh my goodness so i met
sarah michelle geller when we were both
uh young
soap stars she worked out on the street
on all my children while i was on one
life to live
so i met her a couple of times i knew
her already uh socially
and then uh david borianis i had met
through actually nicholas brendan
before uh their uh huge
uh well actually they were all just
having great success on buffy at the
time
and um when i went to guest on buffy
i had already uh had a couple of dinners
with david and uh
and uh and known uh sarah michelle since
the mid mid-90s did you ever date sarah
michelle
gellar nathan oh no no never once never
looks up
i don't know if i believe you but
liliana jimenez what has been your
favorite character to play
the one character you're like you know i
know you have a lot of them i mean it
could be firefly it could be castle it
could be
i mean there's a million but what the is
the one uh it's it's
really it's really hard to just when
someone says what is your favorite what
is the ultimate i mean it changes daily
so i'm gonna just kind of do a gradient
here okay
malcolm reynolds was indeed an
incredible character to play i had a
list of things i wanted to do as an
actor
i wanted to uh shoot a gun i wanted to
ride a horse
i wanted to there's all sorts of things
i wanted to do
on tv a friend of mine and i just sat
down and made our lists
and everything i wanted to do on tv i
got to do in the first episode of
firefly and i had to come up with an
entirely new list
so as an actor uh as a human being
i was a cowboy i was a spaceman i was
shooting guns
i was kissing lady i mean there was just
there was just no end to
the incredible fun that that show was
however short-lived i wish i knew then
what i know now i think i could have
done more you know you look back and you
go oh i was um
now i know different i know differently
how to deal with that
choice or what have you so you're trying
to go too deep into that
now on castle i had
years close to a decade with which to
become intimately uh connected with a
character
um yes he becomes more and more like a
goofy knee
with every passing month but
there was a lot of freedom there to
improvise there was a lot of freedom to
try
things castle was very entertaining
he was very childlike so uh comedy was
i got to have a lot of we did a lot of
comedy we did a lot of comedy
we weren't considered a one-hour drama
yet we weren't accommodating
go figure how do you explain all right
so i understand what you're saying that
you've played many characters but
it sounds like you know those two
characters really there was some
incredible value in those characters
at the same time i had never sung like
that uh
before the public in such a way so
captain hammer
yes uh there was um
i mean what can i say everything i've
done has such a value for me
it's how to pick rey ass
i just wanted to do that ray asalin i
wanted a cough in between ass and
lynn i bet he'd never guess that i'm
immature
will he be uh playing green lantern
again uh will i be voicing him uh
uh probably i i wouldn't say no
they they are very kind about inviting
me in to go and and
do those things every once in a while
and if it's uh if it works
i always jump at it lisa little lisa
lisa williams did you keep any props
or wardrobe from the firefly set
absolutely
would you keep i uh i
have uh one of our walkie-talkies from
firefly
i have my holster and my gun
i uh have a not the original
coat but someone made me a uh
uh a mock-up coat of macaroni's brown
coat
um what else do i have
some of the gold bars we had these gold
bars that turned out to be food protein
bars i had a couple of those
uh some firefly money you're like me i
keep everything my my cast mates always
make fun of me
rosamond's gonna take that
wendy feldblum i just have to read this
one first
thought oh my god nathan fillion can i
be your cougar
no need to ask but total first thought
so there it is just like that
wendy thank you dave dave p plavi any
chance for another
serenity movie get josh back to his
roots
i would like that you think it was a
no-brainer it's always a chance
i i've learned never say never i never
have expectations
i'm learning from this conversation
nathan steph alexander can you give us
any clues about your
tdk character and suicide squad
uh clues um yeah
probably not the first guy you'd want to
call on in an emergency
i like that and looks remarkably young
for his age
this sounds like a fun role oh my god
listen
here's another thing i think is
fantastic about this industry now
getting started is not easy and it's not
fun all the time not every experience
can be
pleasant and sometimes you have to wade
through a little bit of
garbage to get to the good stuff and
as you as you elevate in projects
the level of professionalism i think
comes up too so when you're swimming
down at the bottom i think you kind of
encounter a little kind of
crap here and there but boy oh boy as
you build up you meet people along the
way and everybody continues to keep on
going up
and these relationships continue and you
watch people build their careers and
they
they say hey let's do let's work
together again
yeah i was in one of james's first films
i
i learned so much from working with
james gunn
and uh one of the most important things
i think i learned was i'll work for this
guy
anytime i will work for him anytime
and they have me too yeah no i love i
love him i mean it's just
you know i was supposed to do a small
part on suicide squad and i was so
bummed because i just had neck surgery
and i was like so bummed i couldn't do
it i just always want to go play
okay and i got it thank you very much
for that i don't think it was tdk
it wasn't it
sorry rosie you know because we knew for
james when he was like you know i knew
him
but you know him since before slytherin
i think i've known him for quite a while
but like slither is where we met james
tonight you met in slytherin reminiscer
i auditioned for slither
and i said where are you gonna film and
he said oh we're gonna go up to
vancouver i said oh great i'm canadian
he said
really well
that was it we'll save money he'll live
there
uh matthew jackson do you approach
motion capture acting differently from
traditional acting
buck from halo comes to mind as they use
your likeness and voice
that was very interesting i only did a
couple of motion capture scenes
uh that's kind of distracting thank god
uh oh my god the gentleman
forgetting his name he's he's brilliant
he's uh he played luke cage
in the tv series what was his name ah
ryan
you know and then halo he's mike mike
what coulter
mike coulter thank you very much what a
polite gentleman
what a classy guy
one of those guys who understands work
and has it locked down
he knows how to do his job so we're
wearing these weird
headgears with dots painted all over our
faces and trying to have this like a
totally serious conversation like
it was odd and distracting and something
i'd never experienced before so thank
god for him because
boy he can really bring the gravitas he
brings it down man
he is everything he says is carved in
stone
like it's great um
but i only had to do a couple of scenes
after that they put you in a rig
with 36 cameras and they make you
do all these different expressions and
then all these different sounds
make an e sound like you're happy make
an e sound like you're angry
make an e sound like you're sad and all
the vowels all the co you got to run
them all through
and they learn how to puppeteer your
face with all these dots and all these
cameras they
and then they go in and they do that
later for it just so you don't have to
do you act it out do you act things out
a couple of scenes i did
but the rest of them i didn't wow
they're literally puppeteering
uh leanne pritchett who are your
personal heroes
nathan i will say that my brother
and my dad my parents uh
i uh these are people these are i mean
we look at our parents and i think we
take them for granted all the time but
if you can stick take a step back and
see your
parents for the human beings the people
that they are
um you see their sacrifice see see what
they've done see
how what they've built take inventory
for them
understand their journey a little bit uh
i'm really impressed with the i think
i'm a good guy
i'm really impressed by my brother and
his kids are phenomenal
when i would look at all this that my
parents have built i'm
incredibly impressed i really like my
family i like hanging out
with my family uh that wouldn't be
possible without my parents guidance
they made sure that wow yeah that's deep
it's something i can't really relate to
but
uh sort of with my grandparents you know
my grandparents were
they were that they definitely were
um just always people are always welcome
there it was so easy to hang out with
them they were just even keeled
supportive
um yeah that's that's huge last question
here from the [ __ ] talk and nancy davis
what is the role you drop
everything to play and i'm going to add
to that a role you drop everything to
play or a director that you haven't
worked with that you would drop
everything to work with
uh i'm so terrible with this game
because i'm so bad with the names it's
not a game this is serious grand
budapest hotel
who who who sanders west anderson thank
you wes
anderson thank you i would do any wes
anderson
who would you would be perfect in a
movie like that i'm looking at you now
and i can just see you in a movie like
that
i love their kind of dramatic
underplayed honesty
it's almost like school play kind of uh
honesty
it's so subtle uh and yet
obscure and odd i just love the tone of
those films i would
i mean who wouldn't you work for who
wouldn't you work for
there's so many people i would love to
i'd love to work with clint eastwood
i'd love to work with tom cruise i'd
love to work with ben affleck i'd love
to work with
i i name it how about ryan reynolds
let me tell you something i am so happy
for that guy ryan is one of those people
who has always
just been deserving ryan has always been
deserving
he works really hard he works
really really hard he is no stranger to
dedication
and he's always been kind
that's just when i watch when i see
people succeed it's
it's amazing that people can succeed if
people have that kind of success
and they're deserving of it i just feel
like something's right with
the world and i i love and i
marvel looking at what that man has
built
and who he continues to be to this day
what a gem
yeah he seems that way and you guys do
you still keep in touch
yeah he's a wonderful guy he's a
wonderful guy wow
you know what's what's the what do you
think the end game is for you like
uh do you see yourself one of those guys
is 94 years old having a stroke on the
set and that's how it ends or
you retire do you attire and go go move
out to the middle of nowhere and you
disappear at the age of 70.
you know you said earlier you that you
have no interest in running away from
l.a or anything like that
and nor do i but there will come a time
when it's
time for us to leave when there will be
nothing left
for us here or if they need us they can
just
call us you know what i mean it's like
you know what we really need is a nathan
fillion type
is he still acting because i know he's
really old
and they can just call me and say hey
would you be willing to come and
do something here or if it's a voiceover
i can do it from wherever i
am and because i'll be set up you know i
will but
my plan my plan is to
uh like i said i was interested in a i
am interested in
i'm from canada at western canada some
of my favorite
places in the world are in western
canada
um so i'd like to retire with a place
there but i'd also like a place off in
europe somewhere a little warmer i'd
like a place somewhere
south where i could do some easy scuba
diving i would like to have little
places that i
frequent and just go between
travel with my brother with my family
with
we'll all be retired or just whatever
whatever
i want to have like a kind of a coast
and just call me when you need me
how long is the mustache going to stay
on it's a love-hate
relationship have you ever done a beard
or a mustache i've had little beards and
things my mustache is they're
it's kind of blonde so it kind of looks
funky i i don't look
i mean you that's for real that's rich
that's uh
sort of tom selleck back in the day rich
very and i just trimmed it back it was
it was really low it was covering my
entire
bottom i didn't know i could grow almost
at uh so a little bit's a thrill
uh i'm gonna it's a love-hate
relationship right now i'm gonna say i'm
gonna be honest
it gives me something to do and to think
about that's not the pandemic
and i'm just kind of all for that i've
got all sorts of little hobbies and
goofy things i'm doing michael i can't
even tell you just stuff that entertains
me when i go look what i did
well how long did that take you all to
all probably
uh you know 36 hours but you know you
don't do it in one sitting you just
spread it all out but i
this is the goofy stuff i'm doing are
you filming things are you filming
rookie not right now no the plan is to
go back in the end of september but
we'll see how that works out we're
trying to make it safe
do you think it's gonna change in terms
of like all the stuff that happened you
know with the
you know just the movement and
everything with the police and all that
do you think there's gonna be have to do
a lot of writing to sort of cater to
that to be
of what's happening today do you think
that's going to happen with the show
we've always tried to be an aspirational
show
uh i think that makes us a little
different as far as
cop shows go we're trying to be just a
little more what we're trying i guess
we're trying i mean i hate to speak for
the show but
in trying to be a little more truthful
with police shows
we are although trying to be
aspirational understanding and realizing
now
that the experience that we are
depicting is not
everyone's experience we are
trying to do what is right
as we all as a culture
are educating ourselves and learning as
to what is the right thing to do
and that's that's our goal what are you
watching right now
what are you binging what have you been
what are you binging
oh what am i doing um give me that yeah
i watched game of thrones um wow
a number of documentaries favorite
character real quick on game of thrones
favorite character don't say tyrion
because he's everybody's favorite oh i'm
not she's not not my favorite
all right on the count of three we're
going to say our favorites give me a
second
i am i'm not going to do it right now
but it's going to go all right here
here's what's going on we're going to go
like this we're going to go one two
three the name
ready one two three hound
tywin lannister oh wow that was a that's
a
he was intense that icy cold stare i
would love to work with that man
i would love to work i would love to
work with the hound you're a [ __ ]
you're a kent you're a [ __ ] yeah that
was a good character oh
the hound i just loved him i just wanted
him to
he was like just if the better a person
you were
back then the less your chances were
surviving oh yeah
that was such a good show and people you
know criticize even i did i was like
what the hell happened in this final
season but i'll tell you what
there's a couple episodes in there that
you're like wow so even if
the final episode went to [ __ ] it still
was one of the best series if not the
best series of all time if you ask me
now you see this is where i will
disagree with a lot of people
i am the kind of person i mean
look at any beloved series
it has to come to an end pardon me it
has to come to an
end who has ever been happy
with the end jim morrison
hasn't this been great uh you asked me a
question but you also kind of told me
how to answer it so yes
is this great are you having a fun time
wait hasn't it
what did say it like that buddy you look
amazing about 15 years ago you stopped
aging
yeah right i definitely don't think i
look over my age
but i sometimes feel twice my age
physically sometimes you know my back
will tell me to slow down everyone
somehow that's what happens and i think
you know you always hear that
it's so cliche to hear from like your
grandparents and your parents like oh
you know i feel the same
i don't even know why i'm 70. i don't
feel 70. tell me this
when you first started on smallville
were you like oh i want to do all my i
want to do my own stunts
that was a problem i did a lot of them
yeah i still feel it
oh yeah i would always even like on
comedies and movies like sorority boys
or this or
bringing down the house or whatever i
would do my own stunts and i'd do
pratfalls
and after a while i look back and i go
i wish i would have done all those
things there was a bit you had in
sorority boys
that you watched you and the guys are
fighting
and there's a moment where your
character is
truly upset about something and he said
yeah because i don't have calves like
yours like
you are these stream like a [ __ ] because
i don't have your calves like you just
but it was such a funny moment
but your you your character was so upset
like the honesty in it
i thank you for mentioning story voice
because i don't think anybody saw it but
you know there are some people it's a
little occult
buddy you are very good at your job hey
i
appreciate it i i look you're obviously
great at your job and people love you
and you know i just i look you're really
i've always admired you and you've
always been such a kind person and i
know we don't get to see each other a
ton
and maybe this is the first time in a
while but i hope i get to see a lot more
of you i think you're uh fantastic and i
wish you
all the best continued success and uh
you know you got to give jeff my love
and when this is over
i'd love to come and check out your
collection of things in your house
you got it buddy i love that it's been
over 20 years and we're still connected
this
tickles me i love it thanks for allowing
me to be inside of you today my friend
it's called inside of you anyway i
haven't said that in a while i thought
i'd say it
see you buddy love you man love you too
hey i hope you enjoyed that nathan
fillion thank you again everyone for
listening and uh
subscribing and supporting the podcast
whether you like the guest or not just
listening to
good conversations between two people
and learning something hopefully that's
what you're about
thanks to all the patrons thanks uh for
uh just being so supportive
i mean it's really tremendous and i hope
it continues so i could do this forever
and you guys could be here forever with
me
the handles are at inside insideyou
podcast on
instagram and facebook instagram and
facebook and at insideypod
on twitter i'm also at michaelrosenbaum
on twitter it wouldn't fit so bum and d
michael rose's mom on instagram
so that's it also uh the inside of you
store inside of you online store
a lot lots of great stuff um we're
almost out i think we have like one
tumbler left couple of coffee mugs but
i'm getting new coffee mugs here being
shipped here in a week
tons of wine glasses and they're pretty
badass
and all this stuff for the most part
once i get through it i don't reorder so
uh there's still shirts and stuff
available so check that out uh the last
the 26 december 26th at 2 p.m and 6 p.m
we're doing a stage at show another one
our final one of the year rob and i
playing some covers and music holiday
maybe some holiday songs but uh
come on follow us on stage go to
stage.com
type in uh michael rosenbaum and you
could uh follow me and you'll be uh
aware when we have shows
here's the patron shout outs we have
some dramatic music here
here we go nancy d leah s trisha f sarah
v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h lauren
g nico p robin
jerry w emily k robert b jason w stephen
j
kristen k not kristin krug amelia o
allison l
jess j lucas m raj c joshua d emily s
cjp
samantha m jennifer n jackie p stacy l
carly h jennifer s janelle b carrie b
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tablet 273
ashley r kimberly e crystal h mike e
marissa and
jack s jackass
no jack s slater i love slater ramira
beth b santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p
roshan russian r ray a maya p matty
s tiffany i kendrick f ashley e margie m
shannon matt w belinda n kevin v
james r chris h anusha w aj
osborne h gabby m dave h samantha s
spider-man chase sheila be confused with
sheila e
correct ray h alice alyssa c
tabitha t not to be confused with 272.
uh misha h deb a hi deb
tom and two not to be confused with that
only six two three
that's right ally b not to be confused
with hallie mcbeal
ali g i was hoping henry s katie f
daniela v liliana a joseph c michelle k
maddie waggs uh you guys are all amazing
and uh
couldn't do it without you so thanks for
your endless support we had some new
patrons that i
messaged and uh got some new ideas maybe
brewing for the new year
so uh and then bryce has something
brewing for the end of the year
big thanks to everybody for listening
great guests coming up
next week erica durants lois lane
finally she's on the show it's going to
be great so make sure you tune in
and thanks for tuning in and supporting
the podcast uh
from ryan myself thanks for allowing me
to be inside of all of you
and we'll see you next time thank you
guys if i look tired i am
so don't comment he looks really tired
are you okay michael yeah i
am see you guys i'm fine
i'm fine it's been a [ __ ] year it's
been a [ __ ] long year